hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're in
game number 7 at a 2018 World Chess
Championship in London England between
the champion Magnus Carlsen and the
Challenger Fabiano Caruana who won the
candidates tournament earlier this year
to face off with Magnus Carlsen here in
the world championship we have six games
so far and we have six drawls that
brings us to game number seven in the
second half of this tournament it is a
12 game tournament if we do have a draw
after 12 games doesn't matter if we have
wins until them but if that both sides
are equal in points then we will have
some rapid and blitz after 12 games this
did happen two years ago in Magnus
whatever against there to get karyakin
- was victorious in that but we'll see
before we get to the end of the drawls
we have to see if someone's actually
going to get a victory in the normal
classical chest starts here with Magnus
Carlsen in the white pieces game number
seven he also had him in at game six so
we do flip the white and the black
pieces Magnus Carlsen will have the
black pieces in the final game in game
number 12 if we actually get there but
today madness starts with the white
pieces and he starts out with pawn to d4
so we did see two days ago in Game six
he tried going into the petrel defense
Fabiano extremely well versed in that
opening and seemed to be better going
into the middle game did not end up
doing too much from there
and so you see Magnus Carlsen opting for
something different plays pawn here to
d4 Knight to f6 Knight f3 pawn
d5 upon C poor getting into the Queen's
Gambit line and then pawn to e6 this is
the Queen's came a decline line if this
looks familiar it should if you've been
following the tournament especially
after Bishop to f4 we talked about this
earlier in game number two this is the
same opening that Magnus Carlsen played
and they played the exact same opening
all the way until move
number 10 and players were going so fast
spending almost no time on their moves
and that brings us to this point in the
game now in game number two magnus
carlsen played rook to d1 in this
particular game he decided to change
things up and play Knight to d2 for
those looking at the position curious
why instead of Knight to d2 pawns didn't
come up here to b4 since it's attacking
both the bishop a of the Queen the
bishop can freely take here the pawn
can't recapture the Queen could come
down here to a1 so that's why we don't
see that move and said we see Knight - D
- now as fast as the first 10 moves were
from the players only took a few minutes
off the clock the next four moves took
over an hour and a half for those
actually watching the stream following
along with the game there were times I
didn't have the sound on I was curious I
had to refresh I just felt for sure that
some moves were taking place they were
not just took a long time for both
players to go through the motions trying
to figure out how they're going to
continue Fabiana start out with Queen to
d8 I feel like this is where magnus
carlsen was just not sure what to do
from here I don't think he expected this
move at all because you generally don't
see your opponent get your Queen
involved and then immediately come back
to d8 especially when it's not under any
threat right now so we see Knight to b3
Bishop comes back here to b6 since it is
under attack a Bishop to e2 getting
ready to castle on the King side Queen
to e6 maybe this is better square that
Fabiano wants to get to Bishop to g5
pinning down the knight pawn takes here
on a c4 Knight comes back here to d2
could have also just taken with his
Bishop if he wants to but since he knows
it's gonna be very difficult for his
opponent to hold on to this material he
can take it in a variety of ways he
decides he wants to bring his knight
back here to d2 now he can come up to c4
more aggressive square for the knight he
can also take it with his bishop if he
wants to but this gives him more options
in the game Knight to e5 and then castle
on the
kingside now Magnus did have a lot of
options after the games they always ask
certain situations doesn't matter how
the game ended up they go back and just
say what were you thinking in this
position you know did you plan on the
Queen's game of decline the entire time
or did you take the day off and you come
back to this you just didn't really like
the Petrov or what did you think about
Queens - da - that catch you by surprise
this position right here they did ask
him a lot of questions about and he said
that there was a couple options in his
head that he was going through he wanted
to play something like pawn to f4 but he
just couldn't find any solid lines from
here he also said that he probably could
have been should have been more
aggressive with Knight to e4 but from
here he decided instead to play just
castle on the kingside not very
aggressive for magnus carlsen safe move
absolutely but could have been more
aggressive his King was under no threat
at the moment bishop - a d7 bishop comes
back here to f4 Knight to g6 now
attacking the bishop bishop comes back
here to g3 Bishop to a c6 Knight up here
to a c4 so we talked about how white
wanted to capture this material decides
to go and capture it with his knight
also now attacking this Bishop here on
b6 with the knight attacking the bishop
bishop comes back here to c7 and then we
get the rooks involved into the game
could have brought the rooks and earlier
but now you want to start to control
these open files so rook here to d1 rook
to the 8th just counter-attacking and we
do see some exchanging on the board
immediately met by rook over here to d1
and the rooks come off the board Knight
to d5 nice little outpost in the center
of the board
Queen comes up here to d4 could have
taken immediately if he wants to but he
knows that the knight could come take
here and then he wants to have his Queen
there to take back doesn't want to have
two isolated pawns here with a pawn here
on a c3 as well as pawn to a3 so who
wants to recapture with his Queen he
could come to d2 but since he doesn't
know
what his opponents gonna do he'd rather
have it up here on d4 compared to d2
just because it's more centralized and
so if his opponent does want to wait a
little while he can have some additional
threats on the board things like pawn to
a7 he is attacking so Queen to d4 Knight
takes and then the Queen recaptures here
on a c3 Bishop comes down here takes on
g3 and then the pawn takes here from the
h-file always important to make sure
that you know how to take with your
pawns most people will tell you just
take towards the center not always the
case but this is one example you
definitely want to do that and the main
reason for that is you don't want to
have isolated pawns so if you take with
your pawn from the F file you can see
this pawn isolated here in the stern the
board with two minor pieces and a queen
it just gives your opponent it's
something to attack the rest of the game
whereas you take your pawn to g3 you
still have a nice pawn chain and these
pawns are just gonna help each other so
while you do have double pawns on the G
file it's not necessarily a bad thing
many times you can get rid of one of
those pawns pretty easily
Queen to a d7 a bishop up here to d3
attacking the Knights pawn to a b6 punt
up here to f3 just consolidating a
little bit stopping the bishop from
attacking this pawn down here on a g2
pitcher comes back to b7 Bishop now
takes on g6 and we see the same thing
the pawn takes from the H file does not
want to take from the F file for the
reasons we just talked about pawn to e4
Queen over here to a c7 attacking the
pawn on a g3 so we see pawn be 5
stopping that it is stopped from this
Knights here on C 4 this is defending it
Queen comes down here to a c5 check King
to H to a sticking around a little bit
bishop to a6 attacking the knight and
that comes up to d6 this is a nice
little outpost now the queen is also
defending the pawn as well but it's
tough to really see a
we're attack that magnus carlsen has he
has a good position I think it'd be
tough for him to lose here but it is
tough to see how he will continue
besides go ahead and take with his queen
on a c3 pawn recapture so as far as pawn
structure I definitely liked black's
pawn structure but one thing magnus
carlsen has going for him is the fact
that his opponent has a bishop very easy
to just put all your material on at the
opposite colored square so he has both
his pawns here on the dark colored
squares he can start to move his other
pieces there as well pretty much just
negates all of the strength that this
LightSquared Bishop has f6 from a
Fabiano pawn here to f4 just solidify in
the pawn chain also gave him on the dark
squares as we talked about King to f8
giving him a king involved into the game
King to g1 came down here to e7
you're not gonna kick off you know this
Knight it's a great little outpost King
to f2 King to d7 King starts to come up
to e3 and then all of a sudden Fabiana
says yeah I'm gonna attack this pawn
here on g2 madness really doesn't have
an option he needs to come back to f2
and so Fabiano can essentially force
this action as soon as the King comes
back then we're just gonna repeat and so
after 40 moves the players decide to
draw so 7 games in we do have 7 rolls
much like the last World Championship
will be curious to see if Fabiano can
come back tomorrow and gameit's
break this thing up as he has the white
pieces but hopefully guys are enjoying
the tournament I know there are a lot of
draws most people including myself want
to see a lot of wins but this does
happen once every two years so try and
just enjoy this high-level play as much
as possible but appreciate you guys
watching I'll see you in tomorrow's
video for game number 8